mais on ouvre ce journal avec de la
politique de plus en plus isolé françois
fillon a décidé de maintenir sa
candidature
alain juppé est finalement renoncé
aujourd'hui être le plan b lui dei de
son côté annoncé le retrait de son
soutien la fédération des yvelines s'est
réuni ce samedi pour débattre de la
stratégie adoptée soit un candidat
centriste mais je vois pas vraiment au
jour d'aujourd'hui qui le ferait mais
pourquoi pas ça peut être une
une décision rapide et ultime soit une
hémorragie vers emmanuel macron ou vers
l'abstention est donc forcément si c'est
l'abstention c'est en faveur du front
national et de marine le pen ça va de
soi que donc c'est ce serait la pire des
situations au non nous on milite pour
que effectivement françois fillon se
retire de cette élection
assez rapidement pour clarifier les
choses très très rapidement je suis prêt
à soutenir hama nacre en fait je
soutient emmanuel macron il est pour moi
un homme de gauche et je ne suis pas un
homme de gauche je suis un centriste
convaincu
donc je ne soutiendrai pas monsieur
macron premier tour la question du
deuxième tour et un est une autre
question
j'allais dire qu'au premier tour je
choisis et au deuxième tour et bien
j'irai dans l'intérêt général de la
nation et comme je te soutiendra bien
évidemment jamais là comme nature de
marine le pen il est bien évident que le
candidat au deuxième tour si je dois
être monsieur macron hiller mais voit
mais j'espère bien évidemment ce sera un
candidat de la droite et du centre qui
sera présent au second tour pour se
battre contre marine le pen